they give us a polygon they want us to
find this missing angle here X now the
thing to notice is that when you extend
the side of a polygon like this you get
an angle on the outside which is called
an exterior angle and if you add up all
those exterior angles around the polygon
it's going to add up to 360 degrees and
just remember that at each vertex you're
either going to extend this side or this
side just one but not both okay so
you're going to get one exterior angle
at each vertex there and they all add up
to 360 so in this case you can see we've
got 90 okay because that's a right angle
plus 101 degrees plus 60 degrees plus 80
degrees plus x equals 360 degrees so if
we add these up we can solve this
equation so I'm just going to use a
calculator here so we've got let's see
90 plus 101
let's see 90 plus 101 plus 60 plus 80
okay which comes out to 331 plus x
equals 360 and if we subtract 331 from
both sides right we get let's see how
much is that that's 29 so X would equal
29 degrees so you can double check my
math but basically you're adding all the
angles up on the outside and they're
going to add up to 360 degrees now the
next example it says what is the
exterior angle and a regular octagon now
remember regular means that all the
angles are the same and all the sides
are the same length but the form we're
going to be using here is that again we
know that all the exterior angles add up
to 360 degrees so if we divide them by
the number of angles or exterior angles
here that's going to give us the measure
of one of the exterior angles okay so in
this case it's an octagon we know in an
octagon there's eight sides or eight
angles so 360 divided by eight gives us
45 degrees so all those angles on the
outside are gonna be 45 so I'll just
draw a quick octagon that's like a stop
sign right and you can see if you're
extending that side there's your
exterior angle 45 and you can see each
one of these is going to have a 45
degree exterior angle so I hope this
helped you understand how to work with
you know finding that exterior angle
when you're working with polygons
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon